and we are live welcome everybody to
another YouTube hangout super excited to
be back on with you today I have a
special guest with me Danny who wrote
into me who wanted to interview me on my
time management and productivity tips
for big matchup that he's doing and I
said you know what instead of me answer
my email how about we do it by a YouTube
hangout we can talk about what you're up
to and I much rather give value through
a video form rather than write an email
anyway so Danny welcome aboard
hello how are you I'm good man before we
get into the questions maybe just give a
little bit of context or people watching
they haven't heard of you yet what are
you trying to do with this this roundup
and then and then we come to the
questions yep I'm working at a time time
management
sorry a time tracking app which is
called time my life and our company is
called adapt area calm and my main idea
was to make this huge cost about time
management and to interview the big guns
like you people who know how to manage
their time perfectly and to learn from
you that was the main goal for this post
and I'm now I can can I start to
interview you can I please do it yes
okay okay the first one is what are your
favorite time management tactics so for
me there's a couple things one chunking
my time is probably the single biggest
one that has helped me with my planning
and the concept there is anything that I
do multiple times per day try to do once
per day multiple times per week do once
per week most times per month one per
month that kind of thing yes the the one
that added the most value to me way back
when I first discovered this concept was
email so answering email once a day
instead of answering it constantly I
would be the guy who would pride myself
on fast response so somebody sent me an
email like two minutes later
to have a response back and that was
like my badge of honor that I got back
to them so quickly yeah and then I
realized that I wasn't getting big stuff
done because I was constantly just
getting distracted by email and so
moving that to once a day was one of the
biggest things that freed up my time and
then I applied that to everything else
that I'm working on so you know we're
chatting here on a Thursday afternoon
Thursday is my public-facing day it's
when I'm doing my Google Hangouts I'm
doing interviews I'm doing podcasts you
know whatever involves other people no
meetings phone calls it's always
happening on the Thursday and and you
know most people are and adapt to fit my
schedule Wednesday I do video day and
that's when I go to the studio I'm all
afternoon I'm shooting video Tuesday I'm
working on my book Monday I'm working on
my salsa business that I recently
acquired and so like every day I'm doing
something different and it lets me focus
and not get distracted and part of that
chunking time is you have to be willing
to give up on some opportunities so some
stuff like some reporter writes to me
and says hey can I interview you my
deadline is 4:00 p.m. today and it was
past my email check-in time so like I
don't get in that interview and so it's
being willing to give up some
opportunities because you're focusing on
the really important Oh chuckling my
time has been probably the single
biggest one that's helped me on top of
that the formula of eliminating
automating delegating so taking a look
at your schedule most people are doing
work that they shouldn't be doing be
successful in your career as an
entrepreneur you need to be doing the
things that you can be world-class that
you can be one of the best in the world
and you need to spend as much time as
you can in that area where most people
are spending five to ten percent of
their time on the things that they could
be genius at and ninety to ninety-five
percent of the time doing other
and so it's okay how can we get rid of
some of that other stuff well some stuff
II shouldn't shouldn't even be doing
just eliminated then automated look for
tools technology software to help you
and then build a team and delegate the
rest out so that you end up focusing on
the things you can be best in the world
at and that doesn't happen overnight
that's a process and I get that hey you
mean I have any money to hire a team yet
but you want to work towards getting
there where you are slowly eliminating
the things from your schedule that are
not really really high leverage for you
and then my last one is probably not
using a phone I don't use a phone it's
one of the more unconventional ones and
it lets me be present for when I'm with
somebody so my wife used to hate it at
the start of our relationship like I
can't reach you why don't you get her
phone and now she likes it I'm with her
I'm with her and I'm not checking email
or answering phone calls or texts or
social media or whatever phone I use a
phone for outgoing calls but I don't
have a phone number where people can
reach me and that's really other
people's agenda for your time like a
cell phone is other people's agenda for
your time so at some point I may get a
data plan we'll see like to use apps
like uber another option you the data
plan right now I don't and I definitely
don't want to get a phone number so
that's the more unconventional one with
two more traditional ones okay that's
great can I ask you the second question
which is what is your greatest challenge
when you manage your time the greatest
challenge in managing my time I would
say is be know the balance the
opportunities first something it will
balance the opportunity like somebody
writes in the means is hey Evan here's a
here's this great project that I have in
mind do I take that project
you know like entrepreneurs we want to
we want to do stuff we want to take
projects we want to say yes the things
where were the you know ideas people
like that we see a big vision for
something we want to go and do it and
recognizing the constraints on
perfecting actually get done and also
try
to figure out how much time I need to
have time left on and you know all the
other stuff that I want to do so that's
that's probably the single biggest one
is learning which ones to say yes to
because I think people just say yes to
too many projects and then never see
them through that's probably the start I
think if we want to go a little bit
deeper on it I would also say evolving
the schedule as I evolve myself ancient
grow as a human being interest I have
things I want to do and my schedule
needs to reflect that and so I'm I'm you
know I live by my calendar I schedule
everything in family stuff I schedule in
to make sure that they get overrun by
business I'm I feel something is out of
whack like something is just pulling me
in too many directions I know my
schedule needs to change so an example I
acquired the I invested in salsa dancing
business and then I bought it and now I
needed to spend more time in this
business and trying to like put in
chunks of time here and there just did
it get a day to be able to do it so okay
my whole schedule had to change so that
when this could be dedicated to this
business when I agreed to take on a book
deal writing the book is a lot of work
it's a lot of it's a long process I need
to dedicated the day to do that and so
Tuesdays became my book writing day that
means you got to take away other things
and about I don't know I don't have a
formal thing where like okay every three
months I need to go look at my schedule
but it's probably about that whatever I
whenever I feel I'm being pulled in too
many directions it means that I want to
do something badly but it's not in my
schedule so it's stressing me out so I
need to change my schedule to match my
interest in where I'm going and that
means other things get cut out of the
schedule so the schedule is great when
you make it and that reflects who you
are right now but as you change and
evolve when new things come along you
need to be able to change in evolve your
schedule with you alright
thanks thanks a lot there's one final
question which is do you have any other
tips for our readers where for the
people who are who are going to read our
post and any other general tips which
are going to help an individual to
manage his time or her time better is
your audience entrepreneurs mostly or or
professionals prefer answers it's a
pretty pretty big chunk of people but
our time is big good I would that in
order for you to be able to build the
big dream that you have for you to have
a big impact that you can't do it
yourself that you need to be able to
surround yourself with people who can
help you get there and I think too many
people and they may have tried like your
first hire very rarely works out and a
lot of people try to hire somebody to
free up their own time and then that
person doesn't do a good job and you're
like forget this I'm just gonna do it
all myself you know I know I can get it
done so I'm just gonna do it myself and
not ever hire anybody again and that's a
really limiting view and I understand
where it's coming from
but in order to do something really
impactful and meaningful in order to
having you Aurel you need to have people
on board with you to help you get there
sorry what did you say to scare up sorry
sorry to interrupt if you want to scare
up the process
just yell up yeah exactly and and
everybody has this big vision for what
they want to go but to get there you
can't do it all on your own and so focus
on at some point building the team and
the first person I hired was for one
hour a day that's it an hour a day to do
work he was better at it than I was and
so it freed up more than an hour of my
time every day and so I didn't have the
budget to go out and hire somebody
full-time to work for me right I'm
starting off didn't have a lot of money
but I could afford one hour a day sorry
yeah one hour or day and in that feed a
little bit of my time and that's how it
works I can send these increments so it
also helps train you to be a manager so
you don't
a full-time person right away you know
you're only managing them in small
chunks and give them tasks severe easier
to do at the start and then train them
to do more in to do more and do more but
getting past the mindset of I need to do
everything myself because again then
you're only spending five to ten percent
of your time on the things that you work
like true genius at and want to be the
best in the world that and the rest of
time is being spent on other stuff that
you don't really care about so business
your individual role becomes less and
less important in terms of the value
that's being created and the most
important role that you have is building
up your team being the visionary guiding
them but building up your team yes thank
you thank you very much that it's all
from me okay we have some live questions
you want to take some questions um okay
let's do it we're putting Danny on the
spot too we'll both answer it
okay so Rajiv is writing hey guys trying
to be productive but keep going back to
wasting time are you going what do you
think
are we going first or you go first it's
our Lancer out I'll see what you say now
I'll say something else okay in in this
case usually I was top and I'll make
I'll check if the thing I am doing right
now is the right thing to do probably I
have this this mantra if you work on
something for more than 30 minutes and
it's not working
you just need to rearrange things
something is not right you need to stop
and rethink your strategy or you
probably need to delegate this to
somebody else and for example if you if
you can't there was I don't remember the
guy but there is one very very big name
and he said that if you can't do
something in 60 minutes you probably
need to ask a professional all right
yeah
I would I would also question like are
you doing do you enjoy your work right
like to be a successful entrepreneur you
have to enjoy the process and not just
the result it's about oh I want to build
a business that makes a million dollars
okay great that's your goal but you have
to enjoy the work to get into a million
dollars right if you are a photographer
and you see that as your path but you
don't like photography then you're
always gonna fight this you're always to
be looking for ways to waste time
monetary goal isn't enough to drive you
forward so you have to be motivated by
the work itself now there's still going
to be some days that's suck you know a
lot of days that suck but but if you
don't enjoy the work that you are doing
then I don't think I don't think things
up off works for very long
right like you need to at the end of the
day process of what you're doing and if
you're not for too many days in a row
then then really question and come up
with hmm maybe I should be doing
something else
and that kind of maybe sucks as advice
like for where you are right now it's
maybe a little harsh truth but yeah if
you keep coming back and feeling like
you want at least time that's that's
time and you never get back you know you
want to go and make an impact and change
the world and touch a lot of people's
lives that hour that you'd waste it
today you're never getting back yeah and
then are you always tomorrow in the next
it's never coming back so you you want
to make sure you're spend your time
enjoy doing yeah next up so British
things thanks guys all caps you're
welcome in ranpur sybiz asking hey guys
what do you think is the best way to
begin your business while working full
time what do you think can I go first go
first the most important to rope is not
to not to quit your job yet because he
needs a safety net and he needs a solid
plan I need to cover your expenses were
please six to twelve months or even even
more I had and I'm you need to a kit you
need to cut yes sometime you spend for
up for things which are not important
you need to just paint a time on your
main goal every day for example you need
to work on your idea for an hour or two
every single day after work or in the
weekends and I think this this is very
important to work towards you go every
day every week and to have a safety net
yeah I agree with a lot of that advice
I'm not the guy who does you need to
quit and go full-time on your business I
think a lot of people do that and then
three months later they're back looking
for a job because they've run out of
money well underestimate how hard it is
and how long it's going to take for them
to get to becoming successful so I agree
like you use your evens you use your
weekends you spend at least an hour a
day every single day no excuses right
like you need to build up the momentum
on top of that I also try to find a job
where I'm learning about the industry
the point of having a job is to learn
not just to make money and really agency
then go work at a digital agency ideally
a company with 10 employees or less
where you can get really close to this
CEO founder but to take up on lots of
different opportunities in a small
company you get to learn stuff then in a
big company where you're like pigeonhole
and say this is what your job
description is and your goal is to learn
like you're getting paid to make
connections to learn about the industry
you learn about what works I mean while
you're starting your business and at the
point where your side business can
support yourself not you know buying
Lamborghinis or anything but you know
pay the internet bill when you can do
that and take your food right and so
when you get to that point with your
side business then you can go full-time
and make it better
Adam how do
yes I think there is there's one very
very good quote which I read recently it
was on the Twitter feet of addicted to
success calm and some guy was saying I
don't need a one o'clock alarm clock my
patient wakes me up in the morning if
you're not passionate you're Thomas yeah
I if you're not passionate about what
you do you're still lazy no you need to
be inspired of what you're linked it
says that's an Eric Thomas quote love et
we've done videos on him before on the
channel I agree 100% like you got to
enjoy you got to have a reason to wake
up every day you got to have a reason to
go and do work you got to have something
that fuels that fire you need to go you
need to get the gold yeah and what helps
to I think is having an environment that
will help you so I get it can be hard if
you're not foreigner you're by yourself
you wake up and you're working from your
room you know you may not have an
environment you may not have parents who
support you or friends who think you're
doing a good job and everybody around is
telling you you know you're never gonna
make it go back and get a job do the
safe thing to do so one you need to
figure out what your big goal is that
you are excited by but then to also
create an environment with resources and
ideas and people that make you want to
do more right like maybe you watch this
video and you think wow okay I love this
I'm gonna go work hard that's great you
know for me it's it's 119 in the
afternoon on the East Coast so maybe
you're off firing for the rest of the
day but what are you gonna do tomorrow
like you wake up tomorrow or when that
inspiration is gone so you need to have
something in your environment constantly
that pushes you to want to do more to
think bigger along with having an
important goal Myshkin is that you are
driving forward on your business that's
how you kill easiness yeah Saad is
writing how do I push myself to do
something
when I don't feel like doing it even if
it's important for my goal I don't know
can it go first I'll go first sure one
you know I'm not a big believer in in
pushing myself too much through things
that I hate I try as much as possible to
find another solution right so like
there's something that you don't want to
do so odd and you think it's important
for your goal and there may well be like
hey you want to get your business into
this step and you think you have to do
you have to go like XY go in a straight
line there's often so many different
ways to accomplish a goal and the path
of the most resistance is usually not
the best one to take so you know if you
have to force yourself to do something
for a couple days maybe but if this is
something to be able to do this and I
would try to find a different way to
stand you know as an example and grow in
my business I'm not I don't like doing
sales I'm not the it may be shocking but
I'm not the guy talking to everybody
right on an airplane it'll talk to the
guy next to me and conferences I don't
go up and introduce myself if my
business relied on me going out and
selling and picking up the phone and
calling people I would suck like my
business would not be anywhere this is
not the only way to grow business I
found another way through marketing and
so I'll market myself and create great
content and draw people in I get invited
to speak at events so now people at the
events come and find me
so I don't have to go on come and find
and so building up a marketing engine
that attracts ideal customers to me is
what my focus has been and I'm it's much
less resistant so it's easier for me to
find success and so I think you can do
it you can force yourself for a little
bit but if you have to force yourself
every day you're doing something wrong
you got a flutist stand yeah absolutely
right
Rosa hey guys love your video my
question is I often get distracted by my
cell phone how can i distance myself
from that just with you though Danny
says switch it off I say don't have a
cell phone you can see relevant properly
Danny's yeah I mean I don't use a cell
phone again other people's agenda for
your time but you could have you could
have a role where the phone is not you
know next to you in your office or in
your room or you have braked or a cycle
gate for these three hours I'm working
and I'm not allowing myself to get
interrupted because it's so tempting to
go and look at your Twitter feed or your
snapchat for you to your email and
something might come in and that
distract you from doing big projects
especially when you're in creative when
your creative zone at least for me when
I'm doing creative work I can't be
interrupted like when I'm working on my
book burger thing I shut down my
Facebook I shut down everything because
if I get interrupted even for a second
it's hard for me to get back into where
I was in writing that book and so
anything that I'm doing this I
immediately shut off everything before I
get into it and that's am writing my
book I can't do it
15 minutes here or 15 minutes theater
because I can't write anything good in
15 minutes I need the time my first you
know half an hour sucks and then I get
the ball rolling and if you're
constantly interrupted then you're just
getting crappy results yeah what else we
got lots of questions coming in well how
do you promote a newly started business
is that it's not good when we started
your business
sorry we could please repeat there were
exceptions very bad no it was how do you
print how do you promote your newly
started business it depends I'm
marketer with 11 years of experience and
it's every every single business is
unique it's different and you need to
find your target market you need to find
the place where your targeted prospects
are gathering and when you find this
place you need to invest all your
resources time money etc when you have
right there
it could be social media it could be a
search engine traffic or a paid traffic
etc but if first you need to find your
target market and build about from there
yeah hundred percent the marketing 101
is you want to be where your customers
are and so you know you want to be
looking at where your customers are
hanging out whether it's online offline
and you want to be there now there's a
lot of ways to be there right if you
want to target entrepreneurs there's a
lot of ways to target entrepreneurs you
can do it through social media you can
do it through conferences you can do it
through influencers there's a lot of
different ways to do it so once you know
what your honor where your audience is
you want to figure out for you attack it
like do you enjoy writing do you enjoy
speaking do you enjoy writing in a data
head do you enjoy talking to people and
calling them on the phone like what
overlaps where your customers are with
what your skill set is that's what
you'll find success so like Danny's a
marketer he's here promoting his
business part of what he wanted to do
was create a roundup of people answering
questions around time management right
put that out I don't know how many
people he's interviewing you know we're
gonna share it right I'll share it I'm
gonna share it to to my Twitter feed
I'll send it out hopefully that gives
Danny and his company some more exposure
right that's why he's doing it I mean
I'm assume he's also interested in the
topic and this is you know helpful and
learning for him too but you know
Danny's using his background as a
marketer to do marketing by asking
questions doing interviews for his for
his company and and to give Danny
little encouragement and also
congratulations you know I gave him this
opportunity said hey Danny instead of
doing this as a as a mere evidence to
Google hangout and I want to introduce
you to my audience and and some people
say yes when I do that I just my
standard answer anybody who wants to
interview me it becomes a YouTube hang
it some people love the opportunity and
they they they jump on it now all you
guys watching right we've got 50 plus
people watching who now learn about
gonna live as a video on my channel that
will live forever when people discover
Danny and then he said yes like here's a
moment that maybe Danny thinks oh I'm
afraid of the camera or my connections
like what I was terrified I was
terrified he steps outside his comfort
zone he says yes and here we are and
he's doing a great job and we're all
doing some questions - so know where
your market is so he's coming to me
because I can talk about time management
I can help share with my audience the
story when it comes out but then
leverage what you're really good at and
and don't be afraid to take a little bit
of risk and run your citta and if you're
like if you hate it then that's one
thing but then you should probably go
and do it just to see just to get used
to pushing through the fear so Danny
wrote back and he said yes I'm gonna do
it even though he's terrified of doing
it there anything great and maybe he'll
do it again next time and it'll be
better next time and and now maybe this
becomes a whole other marketing strategy
right and so if you just state your
doing the same things that you're doing
and you're you're constantly ruled by
your fear instead of Google and chasing
opportunities then you're always gonna
be limit have my quick like
congratulations to Danny thanks and
that's it so I know we're kind of
hitting the clock we're bumping up
against the time still tons of questions
thank you guys for watching Danny when
is this thing coming
this thing is going to be live in about
10 or 14 days I will ping you over an
email to your assistant
perfect forward to reading it and I've
linked up Danny's website in the
description below if you want to check
it out thank you guys so much for
watching thank you Danny for joining
continue to believe thank you for and
I'll see you soon